So, the interesting thing about this problem is you have a choice.
Depending on whether you add c or e to the open list first and the first step.
So, you take d out the open list, you add c and e, or you add e and c.
If you do it in this order, then what happens next is you proceed to the end, and when you hit
the dead end, then you reverse and fill in things in the other end.
You may get a out of 7th and g out of the 5th as one possibility, in which case you have 12.
But that's not the only possibility--you could have also, after you put d off the list, add e and then c
because you don't know whether the neighbors are going to be considered, and that'll cost you
to actually expand things in the opposite direction--so if you'd done this way,
then g would be expanded 7th and a to 5th but you'll still get 12.